Mashable has just come out with an
internet bill of rights I think this is
an absolutely brilliant idea let's put
it up on the screen so they're sort of
using it off of our Bill of Rights here
in the United States if we still have
them I'm pretty sure let's start at
number one the user shall have the right
to access the Internet okay sounds good
number two each and every user shall be
offered equal protections of privacy and
free speech regardless of nationality
religion or political beliefs there's a
lot of countries that wouldn't buy into
that one number three the user shall
have the right for his or her view of
the Internet to be uncensored and
unrestricted again a lot of countries
not happy about that the user has the
freedom to choose a control with whom he
or she shares his or her activity or
personal information furthermore data
that a user uploads to an online service
shall not be shared with other users
except that their consent I think they
will call that the Facebook rule number
five the user has the right to his or
her original content works and
information she uploads or produces for
the internet Instagram is not going to
be happy about that the user shall have
the right to terminate his or her
participation with any online service at
any time if a user wants to terminate a
relationship with the web-based service
the user the user shall have the right
to delete his or her user data from said
service onwards seven the users online
data and personal communications
including but not limited to email
instant messages social media audio
video conferences shall have the same
legal protections as a user's
traditional letters phone calls and any
other physical correspondence or records
Gmail actually just won a lawsuit saying
the complete reverse of that this week
number eight no entity government law
enforcement agent corporation or human
may collect examine steal or otherwise
utilize a user's data without the
permission of the user borrowing legally
justified data collection search and
seizure a Britisher James clapper
wouldn't be on board that one number
nine the user shall have the right to
remain anonymous online and shall only
reveal his or her identity to whom they
choose the YouTube commenters definitely
are gonna be happy with that one right
I had number ten the user shall have the
right to use the internet without his or
her activity or communications being
monitored by any government
or agency and pretty much every
government to our agency is watching us
now so nobody's gonna be happy with that
okay so I want to start with you on this
one because you're a big youtuber you
put a ton of stuff out online you guys
both do do you think something like this
is is necessary first necessary I
definitely think there needs to be
rights that are clarified and and
because this is the Wild West in term
the internet the digital space is
something that is being taken advantage
of by so many people and so rapidly and
the growth was so much more rapid than
anyone anticipated so much so that now
you know we're just now trying to play
catch-up in terms of what the rules are
so I think there definitely needs to be
something put in place this particular
bill of rights is very idealistic and I
love it I love it Yuri yeah in theory I
think it's brilliant but I theory I love
the theories but I you know I can see
the holes in it already you know I think
anonymity in the face of ownership is
something that's a little bit you know
I'm not sure how you're gonna play those
two cards at the same time if I you know
I don't wanna hey hey yo Shana became a
persona and Shana Malcolm's name was
nowhere affiliated with it and someone
wants to repost my content how do i how
does the logistics of that get executed
so there's some of these things that are
a little questionable I love that it
reaffirms rights I think the United were
the United Nations in 97 said that
Internet was a basic right for everybody
so I like that they reaffirm certain
things I do think there should be you
know unrestricted use of the Internet
but I do think there are things like the
Patriot Act in place and you know it's a
little unrealistic to think that you're
going to be able to watch and do and use
anything on the internet without some
kind of monitoring and I do love that it
goes out goes clearly to say you no
matter what nation and race and all of
it that's great in theory yeah but you
know there's the argument of the
violation of some of my personal rights
to ensure my safety which is what they
keep you know shoveling that you know
shoveling down our throats they say that
all the time but at the same time if
someone says to me hey this could have
been avoided if you had allowed us to go
into this person's whatever it is a
months ago and that's why you know
you've lost a leg you know
horrible accident oh crap right you've
given me a lot of stuff to work oh no
that was great so it is part of the
problem here
which I think Shawn is addressing that
we got all this stuff too soon we didn't
even know what this was you know what I
mean we all jumped on facebook without
really understanding that we were the
product that our brains I know the
information we put out there is the
product which is why they give it to us
for free
and now we've just sort of lost control
of this like digital beast yeah I think
so and I also think that if people don't
like it when it's spelled out exactly
what Facebook exactly what Gmail exactly
what these places are doing yeah but
they don't stop using them you know what
I mean like Gmail has made it very clear
we are going through your emails yeah
we're looking for keywords and we're
targeting advertisers to you based on
your private emails yeah but people are
like yeah but it's like eight gigs just
keeps going the number keeps getting
higher I'm like Facebook's like yeah
we're gonna share your pictures and
we're gonna share this we're gonna store
all this we're gonna give that to
advertisers yeah then everybody goes but
what about not gonna have a Facebook
page yeah do you think partly it's
because it's not a physical thing so we
just keep clicking YES on all these long
agreements and it's like you don't have
something to really sit there nobody
Scrolls down the iTunes thing Congress
like who's reading all those bills
they're paper like you had a 14 page
contract in front of you you're not
reading it you're like this is a paper
contract I am your chief agent I read
every single page however you're
absolutely right I think it's because
it's digital right you just scroll down
and we sit I acknowledge whatever it is
and it's not a signature so it's like
it's fine I just need to go on to the
next page yeah because you know when
instagrams policies became public and I
was like literally people were upset
about it but when they thought it when
they look back there weren't any changes
rewriting what did it always been right
you just went public it just went public
and you're you're doing what we've been
doing this what are you talking about
why you like this thing that I signed up
for I can't believe with this 14 page
thing you're like yeah but everybody's
on Instagram right so how could it be
bad yeah like yes you know it's funny
when they have the one that you actually
have to scroll down a little bit to get
the button just
light up so you can say except because
they know that people were just hitting
except when they were like oh well make
them scroll down a little cuz that's and
you see they're going like I can't
believe I have to scroll through this